the Dutch court has found three men
guilty of murder for shooting down a
passenger jet over eastern Ukraine in
2014 killing 298 people the court found
that a russian-made missile fired by an
armed group under Russian control
brought down flight mh-17
well I'm joined Now by Simon main whose
20 year old son Richard was killed in
the mh-17 disaster Simon Maine we really
appreciate you talking to us here this
morning about what must be a very
difficult subject for you I wondered
first of all if you could take us back
to to tell us why Richard was on that
flight originally
okay
good morning Anna uh yeah he was he had
finished two years
study at Leeds University
and uh he had got sufficiently good
grades in those first two years that uh
he was offered a place at a foreign
University and uh the university that
came up was the University of Western
Australia in Perth
so Richard was uh flying out to
Australia to study maths and finance
which is what he was doing at Leeds
and to have the time of his life I
suppose
teach the Aussies how to play rugby
because he was a big rugby
but on the morning of the 17th of July
he was going to catch a connecting
flight
to Amsterdam
and uh then the flight was going to go
to Malaysia Kuala Lumpur and then get
the final connecting flight down to
Perth
so that's why my son was
well unluckily on Malaysian Airlines
mh17
yeah so an absolutely appalling tragedy
for you to to have to suffer and send
our condolences to you
what was the aftermath of that like for
you and what kind of support did you get
from the UK what did you make of the
reaction overall
exemplary I would say
uh we were looked after by Family
liaison officers both here in
leicestershire where I live here in
leicestershire where I live and also
Metropolitan family liaise and officers
every every aspect of what happened in
the aftermath was so professionally done
both by uh the Dutch and the UK and it
really made
made me aware that and what it meant to
be part of a sort of modern
Advanced Democratic country
and now a Dutch court yesterday has
found three men guilty of the murder of
those on board including your son of
course and has handed down life
sentences
what do you make of that verdict what
did you feel when you heard that
let me just uh take you back a little
bit Anna before I answer that question
this court case has been going on for
two and a half years and we've actually
every Fortnight we have emails from the
Dutch Court we have emails from the
foreign office we have emails from the
lawyers Stewart's law in London
the Metropolitan family AIDS and
officers are contacting us so we've
we've been having this sort of almost
bombardment of information for two and a
half years and at times uh it's easy to
lose interest in the whole process of
the Court
excuse me because
at the end of the day
at the end of the day you're sort of not
interested in
all this legalese is that phrase that
was used in
the previous article you just want your
son back you know you want him back for
Christmas
you want to be able to send them a
present on his birthday you want to be
able to phone him up when Leicester city
be Nottingham foreign just simple things
and those are quite often the emotions
that I have felt over this last two and
a half years but I haven't remained in
that sort of somewhat selfish State I
suppose because this whole court process
has just been absolutely
terribly important and it goes to the
very essence I would say of what it
means to be part of a free Democratic
State like the United Kingdom or like
the Netherlands
it goes to the heart of what it means
for nation states to be able to deal
with each other
I mean there's a rogue conflict and
somebody decides they're going to shoot
down an airliner well there has to be
some judgment on that by the
International Community
so although at times as I've said one is
just completely disinterested
on the whole I haven't been and I've
been out to the court we gave a victim
impact statement only about four months
ago
in front of the judges this whole
process to me is just so important and
not because of the verdicts
you know in a sense I don't care about
the verdict because
within a couple of weeks of the plane
being shot down it was quite transparent
that the Russians had sent in some
artillery and had shot this plane down
and you know all the denials and the
misinformation that the Russians came
out with well you know you treat that
with a pinch of salt it's a bit like the
other day when they accused the Royal
Navy of blowing up a gas pipeline in
everything the Russians say and do is
our lies and disinformation and nobody
should be in any doubt that everything
we hear from the likes of lavrov to the
United Nations
command should command no respect
so having said that when I heard the
judgment
to my mind whatever whatever the court
had decided was to be the verdict that
would have been fine with me because
I've watched this process and I
understand that whatever whatever they
came out with would be the correct
verdict now they happen to have come out
with a verdict which matches the verdict
I would have liked to have seen so my
response to that
certainly not Elation that is not not an
emotion that comes anywhere near the
sort of just a small sense of
satisfaction that I was witnessing the
law in action I was witnessing proper
civilized
International States from the Free World
behaving as they should so satisfaction
that no more
well Simon main it's been a real
privilege to talk to you today thanks
very much indeed for for joining us and
telling us a little bit about your son
Richard and your reaction to that
verdict we really appreciate it
thank you